Percent literally means per 100.
That's where the
word comes from.
Cent from cents or century or
any of those words means 100.
So if someone tells
you 7 per cent--
and I'm separating the word so
it makes a little more sense--
they're really saying 7 per 100.
This is the same
thing as 7 per 100,
which is the same thing as a
fraction as 7 per 7 per 100.
With that out of
the way, let's see
if we can write 0.601
as a percentage.
Well, we essentially want to
write it as something over 100.
So you could view
it as-- I'll just
rewrite this part
right over here.
You could write it
as 0.601 over 1.
This is obviously
the same quantity.
If you divide
anything by 1, you're
still going to get
that same anything.
And I'm going to multiply
it by 100 over 100.
Obviously, this won't
change the value.
This is just 1 here.
But what this does is it'll
give us a fraction in term
with the denominator being 100.
So the denominator, if I
multiply these two characters
right over here in
the denominator,
the denominator of our
product is going to be 100.
If I multiply 0.0601 times
100, what am I going to get?
Well, every time I multiply
it by a multiple of 10
or every time I
multiply it by 10,
I'm going to shift the decimal
over to the right once.
So if I multiply it
by 10, I'd get 6.01.
And if I multiply
it by a 10 again
or if I multiply it by
100, I'm going to get 60.1.
So 0.601 times 100 is 60.1.
Let me rewrite that again.
If I were to write 0.601, and
I want to multiply it by 100,
shift the decimal once,
I multiply it by 10.
If I multiply it by 10 again, or
essentially multiply it by 100,
I get 60.1.
So this is times 10.
This is times 10 again.
I've essentially
multiplied it by 100.
But now we have it
in the form we like.
We have 60.1 over 100.
Or you could rewrite this.
This is the same
thing as 60.1 per 100,
which is the same
thing as 60.1 percent.
And we'd obviously want to write
it then as 60.1 percent, as one
word, or 60.1, and we'll
just use the symbol-- 60.1%.
We are done.